Por que que a gente só sente vontade de
mijar quando Já tá deitado o cara se
arruma todinho deita na cama para
encontrar uma posição que é muito
difícil você encontrar aquela posição
que você fala achei para sente sono e
falar hum estou com vontade de dormir é
os organismos as células [__] Leonildo
Será que já é hora de mijar ele não tá
com vontade de mijar não leonaldo ô meu
Deus agora vamos poar um mijo que não
tem verdade eu tô é viajando nada a ver
o cara bocejando a gente querendo
inventar mesmo ah o cara vai pro quarto
escoba os dente bem pertinho da privada
Leonildo a privada vem aqui do lado será
que não era bom já mijar logo Ronaldo
não V aborrecer o rapaz com vontade de
mijar uma hora dessa aí o caba deita na
cama encontra posição sem brulho tá no
ponto já tá tudo no ponto pegando no
sono Leonildo vai leonaldo Bora mijar
mijar NS não pode dormir sem mijar B
mijar Quero mijar Bora mijar Bora mijar
mijar Bora
mijar lá vai tu levantar tudo de novo e
andar devagar para não despertar sen não
acorda e só dorme lá PR 3 horas da manhã
eu acaba tem que andar devagarinho